There is no cloud,
it's just someone else's computer.
This is a meme that has been floating
around the internet for a while and
it's true and it's fine,
realizing that can actually help.
It's just a computer.
So you can do the same things
you already know how to do,
like run virtual machines on it.
But since it's someone else's computer,
they will take care of the hardware.
While there are some companies that
maintain their own private clouds,
most people use a cloud
that is run by others.
There are a lot of
options to choose from.
Large public cloud providers,
small specialized providers,
open source projects that
let you host your own cloud.
It's hard to pick what to use.
Let's explore the most popular options.